[Music]
attack on titan is the best anime that
people don't watch anymore and i say
best because it has delivered some of
the most well-written surprises i have
ever in my life witnessed the series
gained worldwide mainstream popularity
during the summer of 2013 with its high
concepts and breathtaking visuals
however you might best remember it as
that one show with naked giants and an
amazing theme song despite all of this
however due to a full year-long hiatus
between the first and second seasons the
vast majority of folks that got into the
series originally never picked it up
again and with its third season having
just wrapped up before the big final
season next year I gotta say it's a
shame more people aren't watching a show
that has delivered time and time again
without fail has been attack on Titan
delivering upon every promise twist turn
and pay off today we are jumping in and
breaking down the genius behind a great
surprise through the cruel world of
attack on tight
strolling on hercynian cured filtered by
D by Judas
you might not know this but before we
sit down to watch anything new as
viewers we unconsciously make a wish
please let this be good let it be an
experience I've never had before let me
see the world in a new way we want to
laugh at things we have a lot that
before to be moved by things that we
haven't experienced and as a result of
that when an episode begins immediately
we start creating expectations thinking
this will happen or that will change and
if the story isn't worth telling or the
writer hasn't done their job the story
will play out the way the audience
expects it to in other words the
audience prays first surprise the
reversal of expectations without
compromise and no I don't mean
subverting expectations for the sole
purpose of it being a surprise I mean a
surprise that's rooted within the story
let me explain there are two kinds of
surprise that writers utilize to take
their audiences on a ride the first
being true surprise true surprise
reveals itself through sudden revelation
and what makes this true surprise is the
sudden rush of insight that immediately
follows it it's the aha moment you had
all the pieces to put it together but
you never did and when it's revealed
suddenly all of those pieces fall into
place and it all makes sense this is
meaning the idea that everything you've
watched happened for a reason or as the
writer behind all of your favorite Pixar
movies Andrew Stanton puts it
storytelling is joke-telling it's
knowing your punchline your ending
knowing that everything you're saying
from the first sentence to the last is
leading to a singular goal and ideally
confirming a some truth that deepens our
understandings of who we are as human
beings throughout the entire story of
attack on Titan there's been a number of
small revelations each one building off
blast and when the ball finally drops at
the end of season 3
Aaron suddenly comes to realize who the
Titan that killed his mother really was
and that she was the reason he was able
to use the coordinate power to control
the Titans all this information is
received by us in an instant without
words we are on the same page as Aaron
and if done correctly this new
understanding retro actively enriches
the prior events of the story that we've
experienced providing a new lens for
which to view the world through this is
the meaning the viewer is looking for
the revelation of truth beneath the
surface of the fictional world the cheap
surprise
this is the second type of surprise and
it's known as the cheap surprise this
isn't to imply that it has no value just
that it requires significantly less
build-up and effort to achieve the
desired effect than the prior true
surprise we explored earlier instead of
revealing new information this surprise
preys on the expectations of the viewer
in order to achieve its desired effect
in a show like attack on Titan the
viewer expects that Eren the chosen one
with the tragic past after rallying his
comrades will win the day we have our
expectations and then reality attack on
titan utilizes this to reinforce its
themes of a harsh and cruel world
communicating that not only could
anything happen but that no one is
really special and despite the fact that
Aaron does come back from this it's not
because he's special it's because he
happens to have been given abilities
that are nothing about him as a person
is intrinsically unique this particular
surprise type although effective is
abused often in storytelling for example
in Jurassic Park 3 our main character is
flying in a plane suddenly he wakes up
to find that something is wrong
there's no one flying the plane as he
begins to panic he turns his head to see
a dinosaur staring at him smash-cut it's
a dream Allen this scene creates an
artificial audience expectation that
something terrible happened to the crew
and that he will have to land the plate
himself but the reality that hits adds
nothing to the story and only diffuses
and entirely extinguishes the suspense
that was built up the only reason this
scene exists in the first place is to
give the audience a shock to keep them
alert it can easily be cut out entirely
and nothing would be lost in the process
in other words this is entirely
circumstantial and as a result is
meaningless in comparison the vengeful
hero charged that Aaron led in Episode
five is essential for the story for
without this scene without this sudden
reality check he wouldn't have found
himself in the specific circumstances
that led to him uncovering his Titans
power and ultimately the truth much
later so what's in the basement this is
a writing concept widely known as the
mystery box as coined by JJ Abrams
terms of the content of you looking at
stories you think well what are stories
but mystery boxes there's a fundamental
question in TV the first act is called
teaser it's literally the teaser it's a
big question mystery in terms of
imagination the withholding of
information you know doing that
intentionally funnily enough a great
example of how to successfully establish
and ultimately ruin a mystery box can be
observed with a TV show JJ Abrams wrote
lost the island itself acts as a mystery
box who else is on the island what's
going on there
questions arise around the island and
its mystery however the ending sort of
doesn't land in a satisfying way for the
majority in all reality the nature of a
mystery box is pretty easy to establish
however the longer the mystery box is
left on opened the more complicated and
near impossible it becomes to deliver
something satisfying particularly if you
are making it up as you go but attack
untighten knew exactly what I was doing
from the very beginning and boy does it
pay off as I said earlier in the video
great stories create meaning we look for
storylines to connect we consistently
strive to find correlation speculating
thinking and predicting what the answer
will be around the next corner who's
behind that mask what's on that letter
what's in that basement with the shot of
a simple photograph without a word being
uttered it entirely reshaped our
understanding of the world without
contradicting retconning or compromising
established parts of the story in the
slightest this is damn good storytelling
and it's reinforced by this quote from
Robert McKee the story must build to a
conclusion beyond which the audience
cannot imagine another now this doesn't
mean to surprise for the sake of
surprising it specifically worded such
that meaning and reasoning takes
priority when we see this photograph we
get a better frame of reference for
which to view the world in other words
this reveal had purpose it had meaning
it had something of substance to say and
this next scene is no different
this scene right here was the first
moment I realized that a con Titan
wasn't just another TV show but a
classic in the making ignoring the
master stroke that was right or
revealing this vital piece of
information so casually to air it out of
nowhere oftentimes these sorts of scenes
where the antagonist reveals themselves
fall flat and that's usually a result of
poor planning where the writer might
select a random character to become the
villain because he needs one and as a
result it can feel really forced if
there weren't any signs of corruption
prior this is not the case with attack
on Titan for if you were to go back and
watch from the very beginning knowing
what you do now about Reiner Annie and
Bertolt you would notice a plethora of
interesting choices of dialog suspect
visuals in Opie's and strange actions
committed by these individuals in other
words attack on Titan gave you all the
necessary pieces to solve this mystery
and that's the most important part in
order to deliver a satisfying conclusion
to a mystery all the pieces of the
puzzle need to be available to the
viewer if they're not then the viewer
could never have solved it and as a
result you'll never hear them say oh it
was him that makes sense of course or
worse again you inject coincidence and
ultimately meaninglessness into your
story a show like attack on Titan makes
promises and by masterfully wielding his
pen se llaman has carefully crafted
twists and surprises with Grace and
precision unlike anything I've ever seen
time and time again where lesser shows
would have resigned themselves to
meaningless coincidental deus ex machina
attack on titan manages to find meaning
in the most unpredictable of ways in my
experience there have been very few
shows that have delivered such
unrelentingly consistent and superb work
all the way through its visuals are
melancholic and spectacular the dialogue
purposeful and dramatic its music
haunting and ethereal the first episode
the first scene the first seconds of any
story makes a promise to all of us a
promise that there is truth beneath the
surface of this fictional world and with
a courageous charge into its final
season attack on titan shingeki no
Kyojin I'm certain will continue to
surprise excite and
importantly we'll keep the promises it's
made to all of us to its fans to me and
to you 2,000 years from now